eldon ring is getting easier on pc
monster hunter rise sunbreak has a
release date and pricing plus game pass
is getting more games surprise surprise
so let's kick today's video off with
something that's going to make some
elven ring fans very upset there's now
an easy mode mod for pc players
this mod reduces enemy damage by 50
adds a 25 damage buff to players and
boosts rune games by 10. so essentially
it makes you an overpowered machine very
fast and you can probably turn it off
after grabbing a boatload of runes and
leveling up a bunch this low key makes
me wish i bought it on pc but it's okay
i'm still having fun roughing it out
with the default difficulty on
playstation 5. but if you're the
opposite of me and want a more punishing
experience then you definitely should
check out the prepare to die hard mode
mod this boosts the damage defense and
resistance of enemies while also
improving their ai in my opinion this
sounds like torture but i won't yuck
your yum if you're very excited to
install this one our next story also
deals with killing monsters in an open
world but this time on switch a console
that elden ring is not available on i'm
of course talking about sun break the
new expansion for monster hunter rise at
today's digital event it was announced
that the game will release on june 30th
and multiple versions are available to
pre-order starting today there is the 40
standard digital version the 50 deluxe
digital and a 70 dollar bundle that
includes the base game as well avid fans
can also get their hands on a 100
physical collector's edition that
includes stickers an amiibo a steel book
case and more hit the comment section
and let me know which version you're
getting but that's enough of the
pre-order talk let's talk about
preloading now because if you're a
nintendo switch online plus expansion
pack member you can download the first
wave of new mario kart 8 deluxe tracks
right now that way you'll be ready to
hit the gas tomorrow when the tracks are
released this first wave will include
paris promenade tokyo blur and ninja
hideaway from mario kart tour toad
circuit from mario kart 7 coco mountain
from mario kart 64 coconut mall from
mario kart wii shroom ridge from mario
kart ds and sky garden from mario kart
super circuit but maybe racing plumbers
isn't your thing and you'd rather shred
some gnar while shredders is coming to
game pass on march 17th along with
dungeon of the dungeon of the word i
can't pronounce the amulet of chaos not
to be confused with chaos from stranger
of paradise xbox gamers can also look
forward to crusader kings 3 for console
on march 29th and weird west on march
31st my birthday and each one of you
watching right now is required to get me
a gift thanks in advance meanwhile game
pass ultimate subscribers can take
advantage of ea play and whip around in
f1 2021 on march 24th and before we
close out i just want to tease all you
splinter cell fans congrats on the new
book if you read it really really slowly
it'll probably hold you over until the
next game comes out
i'll see you again tomorrow
[Music]